this was a run on a bank with a
difference in Silicon Valley not regular
customers of a High Street Bank but Tech
firms CEOs here start up bosses
Desperately Seeking their cash they just
came out and told us that the bank is
shut down Silicon Valley Bank svb is
part of the tech establishment here
propping up new Ventures it's been the
bank for startups for 40 years and it
collapsed in just 48 hours we relied on
SVP as our bank and the the key question
is are those funds going to move as
planned on Monday morning on Tuesday
there was no outward sign of a problem
but then a surprise announcement from
the bank on Wednesday they needed to
raise more than two billion dollars to
offset Bond sale losses they'd failed to
manage sudden interest rate Rises
and this is what the investor Panic then
looked like the 16th largest bank in
America failing in real time
at its branches the notice is informed
customers that 250 000 of their deposits
are covered by government compensation
schemes but that's hardly a reassurance
97 of svb's accounts have well over that
limit in them we had more than 215 in
this video How concerned
I am pretty concerned the key questions
now what will happen on Monday morning
when the banks and the markets open and
how widespread could this be here in
Washington where svb has a branch the
government is doing what it can to calm
nerves but in the UK Sky News has seen a
draft of a letter sent to the chancellor
by dozens of early stage companies
warning of an existential threat to the
UK Tech sector
the letter to Jeremy Hunt says the
majority of the most exciting and
dynamic Tech businesses bank with svb
and have no or limited diversity in
where their deposits are held
it continued the bank of England's
assessment that SVP going into
Administration would have limited impact
on the UK economy displays a dangerous
lack of understanding of the sector and
the role it plays in The Wider economy
both today and in the future
and at the White House one of President
Biden's top economic advisors was made
available to calm nerves our banking
system isn't is in a fundamentally
different place than it was you know a
decade ago and that the reforms that
were put into place back then really
provide the kind of resilience that we'd
like to see so we have every faith in
our Regulators but as she spoke on Wall
Street the U.S banking sector was down a
little over four percent a nervous wait
now through the weekend for investors on
Monday they'll find out how much they've
lost and we'll all find out the knock-on
mark Stone Sky News in Washington